así lucía en junio de 2021 la
infraestructura de mariupol en imágenes
de satélite así se veía el 9 de marzo
después de los intensos bombardeos que
alcanzaron incluso un hospital
materno-infantil a gabón bandas el
ataque aéreo en el hospital de
maternidad es la prueba final la prueba
de que está ocurriendo el genocidio de
los ucranianos ukraine
europeos no pueden decir que no vieron
lo que pasó con los ucranianos
lo que pasó en mariupol con la gente de
mariupol y decenas de pacientes tuvieron
que ser evacuados muchos heridos y entre
ellos madres en labor de parto
repito donde llevamos a los heridos a
los niños de la maternidad
a los hospitales más cercanos el
bombardeo se produjo mientras se
mantenía en vigencia el acuerdo de un
corredor humanitario para la evacuación
de civiles pero rusia negocio
responsable a través de su vocero dmitri
peskov el kremlin respondió que sus
fuerzas no disparan sobre blancos
civiles sin embargo los ataques sobre
ciudadanos son cada vez más cruento
naciones unidas asegura que al menos 500
16 civiles fallecieron en las primeras
dos semanas del conflicto aunque la
cifra podría ser mucho mayor
wii
estamos tratando desesperadamente de
facilitar un diálogo entre las partes
para garantizar acceso humanitario
sostenible a una ciudad como mariupol y
otras y en ese sentido es titular mayer
por el software volver el tema de fondo
hoy es que la situación es realmente
apocalíptica para la gente y está
empeorando kevin warsh mariupol ha
estado bajo asedio desde el primer día
hoy carece de agua potable electricidad
calefacción y alimentos y medicinas
comienzan a escasear la ciudad portuaria
frente al mar azov no ha podido evacuar
y 200.000 personas tratan
desesperadamente de abandonarla arrasada